-Welcome back.
-It's good to be back.
What a nice --
What a nice audience.
-It's a lovely audience.
I think we're all equally
excited you're here.
And congratulations.
Since the last time
you were here,
you won an Emmy for "Barry"
and a Peabody Award.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's really exciting.
-Yeah, thank you, man.
-And you were actually
in the building.
You were doing Willie Geist's
show today.
-Yeah, I was.
-Doing press for "Barry."
And you got -- this is very --
never happened before.
-No.
-You used to play
Keith Morrison on "SNL."
-I used to play
Keith Morrison on "SNL,"
the "Dateline" guy,
who's one of my personal heroes.
-Yeah.
-He makes me laugh.
I don't know if you know him.
He likes to do -- tell
terrible true-crime stories
in a very singsong kind of way.
[ Laughter ]
Ah, well.
Yeah, so --
-So you met him!
-I met him today!
-You finally met him.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I was -- it was like
the Beatles, and I was like --
[ Screaming ]
Yeah, I was freaking out.
-Was he --
Does he like the impression?
-I hope so.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I go, "I hope you --
Did you like the impression?"
He went, "Ah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, no.
It was very good, very good."
And then, yeah,
yeah, but I was nervous.
I hope he --
But he was very sweet. Yeah.
-That's great.
And then you were back at "SNL"
earlier this year
when our friend John Mulaney
hosted.
-Yeah.
-Is it fun to go back and do
a little cameo on the show?
-Yeah. No, it was a blast.
It was so much fun.
And like, you know,
it's just good
seeing everybody
and things like that.
I mean, I was gonna go back
and just do
the talk-show sketch.
-The game-show with --
-The game-show sketch.
And then they were like --
I was watching
the Michael Cohen thing,
and I saw Jim Jordan on there,
and I was like,
"I'm gonna have to
play Jim Jordan."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And then I showed up,
and Lorne was like,
"So, I don't know if you watched
the Michael Cohen,
but there's a guy
right in your zone."
[ Laughter ]
You know?
And I was like, "Great."
-One of the nice things is you,
of course,
when you come back
and do a cameo,
you don't have to do
the crazy hours as much.
But one of the upsides
of the crazy hours
is the fun that you have at
like 4:00 in the morning.
-Mm-hmm, yes.
-You were recalling
a thing Fred --
Fred Armisen used to do to me.
-Yes, Fred Armisen would --
He would mess with Seth.
So, Seth was the head writer
when I was there,
and Seth worked incredibly
long hours.
And Seth would get
very little sleep.
And so when Seth
would go home and sleep,
Fred would just be like --
Around 4:00 he'd be like,
"Hey, man, do you think
Seth's asleep?"
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like, "Yeah."
So he would call Seth,
pretending that he was, like,
a morning, like, zoo-crew guy.
[ Laughter ]
And that -- So the bit was that
Fred was being interviewed on
a radio show, and he gave out
your phone number live.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So you would hear -- he would
have you on speaker phone,
and you'd hear like, "Hello?"
And he'd be like, "Hey!
We're on with Mr. Seth Meyers!"
How's it going?"
And then Fred
would start apologizing.
He'd be like, "Seth,
I'm so sorry. I am so sorry.
I didn't know they were gonna
read it out loud on the air.
I gave them your phone number."
And you're like,
"Wait, what is going on?"
[ Laughter ]
We would all be dying laughing.
-Yeah, I was not happy.
-And you were like --
then we'd hang up, like,
[Bleep] you, Seth. Bye."
[ Laughter ]
-This is obviously a very --
-[ Laughing ]
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, look, I can look back
on it and laugh.
-But you worked so hard.
You worked, like,
such crazy hours back then.
-Yeah, Fred was -- like, Fred
could always find that time
where you were so tired and you
didn't want any nonsense,
and he would come and bring you
such delightfully
crafted nonsense,
that you had to sort of
tip your hat.
-Yeah, you would be like,
"No, that was great, man."
I remember, he had another bit
was that, people would always
bring us gifts after they would
host, remember?
-Yeah.
-So, like, someone would host.
You would get, like, cupcakes
the next day.
It'd be like, "Melissa McCarthy
sent us cupcakes," or whatever.
And I remember Fred would just
come in with like --
it would be, like,
a six-pack of Coke,
but, like,
four of them were missing.
[ Laughter ]
And he would be like,
"Hey, guys, look what
Steve Martin got us."
[ Laughter ]
And then,
if something terrible --
Do you remember in pitch --
I'm sorry, in pitch,
if something really terrible
had happened in the news...
-Yeah.
-...he would say Colin Jost --
So, he would pitch -- we would
go around the pitch meeting.
Lorne Michaels would be like,
"Seth?"
And then Seth would pitch.
And he would go around,
and we'd all pitch ideas.
So, it was Fred,
and then Colin Jost,
and then if something terrible
had happened in the news, like,
I don't know --
-A tragedy.
-Yeah.
-Like the guy raised a girl
in his basement or something.
He'd be like,
"Hey, did you read the thing
about the girl in the basement?
I think that's terrible,
but Colin wants to write a piece
about it. I don't know why."
[ Laughter ]
Colin would be like --
-He would also do it.
-He would be so nervous.
-He would also do it with people
that definitely like --
the kind of host that definitely
didn't know who Colin was.
-Yeah.
-So it would immediately
be like --
They'd be like,
"Oh, I don't like that man."
-I'm not gonna work
with him all week.
-"I don't want to do his thing."
-Yeah, and Fred would be like,
"I don't know why he wants to do
a piece about that,
but it's his thing.
You should ask him."
[ Laughter ]
Colin would be like, "Uh..."